fear is not real the only place that
fear can exist is in our thoughts of the
future it is a product of our
imagination causing us to fear things
that do not at present or may not ever
exist that is near insanity do not
misunderstand me the danger is very real
fear is a choice
well debt can't I choose not to be in a
sham long movie tonight
now catch a stupid space suit on Jaden
ooh
this is like being in karate with no
cries I heard that
[Music]
oh I'm in this tough guy remember it so
you don't have to today we take a look
at 100 come I don't I just get by the
fly so let's take a look something
important to keep in mind this time
around is unlike his other films
Shyamalan is not entirely to blame for
this one Will Smith's son Jaden was
something of a rising star
so DISA meant his status will took it
upon himself to write a story starring
his son that would hopefully lead to a
sci-fi franchise there was just one
problem
that sucked that is correct oh it sucked
all right it was reported that this film
started out as number one on opening day
but word spreads so fast that it slid
down a slot the next day and was so bad
that slipped down another slot the next
yep
the film was so bad that the public felt
a civic duty to alert as many people as
quickly as possible about its
horribleness but like I said even though
the movie has Shyamalan CEO program
business you can't ignore the ego hand
job that the Smith family is obviously
giving itself for example get a load of
wheels intro over Jaden's narration I've
heard stories of earth a paradise until
we destroyed it the founding of the
United Ranger Corps 1000 years ago was a
global military effort an evacuation of
earth dude what's with the accent with
your mother Matthew McConaughey the
aliens released to us
oh yeah quits I know did we forget to
mention there's aliens in this world
there's aliens in this world quite
pointlessly to be honest as we never see
or find out anything about that hell we
don't even know what they're called
they're just referred to as aliens it
makes sense that they have them be the
ones that destroyed the earth but then
we couldn't get our man a deluxe
environment message that I'm sure this
film is the first one to introduce
technically blind the Ursa sees humans
based on the pheromones
secrete when frightened they literally
smell our fear so the Earth's up wait a
minute they name the pets of the aliens
but not the aliens themselves traces
guys start wiping the human race out but
then a lone hero writes himself into the
story in that answer came in the form of
the prime command a savage I'm sorry
what was that
totally run-of-the-mill average name
again the prom command is Savage
what's lieutenant man awesome already
taken look at this shot it's like the
penis compensation of introductions the
Hummer pickup truck and convertible all
rolled into one
he's believed to be so completely free
of fear that to an Ursa he is invisible
will everybody already wants to be you
you don't need to build yourself up like
this this is like Hugh Hefner trying to
convince us he can shoot lasers from his
eyes there's just no need we're fucking
jealous enough so on the Nova training
grounds we see a young group of students
wearing the same skin tight jumpsuits
that are pretty much worn in every
fucking Future movie don't pass him
that's Will Smith's kid your test scores
are very impressive in the classroom you
are an outstanding ranger but in the
field you collapse um Wow you never
showed us an example of that I'm not
advancing you Jesus I said this a
million times on Milan's show don't tell
or at least have what you're showing
match up with what you're telling based
on the two seconds from what we've seen
how is he not performing well is it
because he cut in line while running I
think in etiquette courts could clear
that right up
we then see cypher Raige come home to a
world so clearly technologically
advanced that apparently they need
rubber bands on their chopsticks I was
not advanced to Ranger you were not
advanced to Ranger
I was not advanced to Ranger sir as you
can see cypher Raige will never not be
funny is a man who has built his life
around having
motion so he can defeat the enemy except
for this very strange out of nowhere
spaz out are you asking me or telling me
I go to my room sir do not sit down it's
weird because he doesn't act like this
at all throughout the rest of the movie
even in scenes where he should be angry
he plays a very bland and dull most of
his performance it's like watching the
dead corpse of mr. Potato Head yet for
some reason he blows up here may I go to
my room sir do not sit down
you will not make me have an emotion in
a Shyamalan film again I just love how a
random act of no reason or logic
suddenly looks futuristic as long as
it's a hologram
I mean what is she doing we have no idea
but it's all science and shit so I guess
we're never supposed to question it hey
Tamara what you doing I'm just
pointlessly waving my hands in front of
these shapes is it as a gamer no just
these shapes the future last visit to
vito's flying tomorrow supervising
training and after it's completed I'm
announcing my retirement well clearly
you've retired from this performance oh
I think it'd be a very smooth transition
maybe I'll work with you that boy in
there is trying to find you
he's a feeling boy ah intuitive boy I'm
sorry
IG pet rocks that feel more than this
kid has to father so being a feeling boy
with a father who wants his family back
they decide to finally look the issue in
the eye and confront it even if it takes
hours
Becky bags you're coming with me to a
feetoes good talk there son next week
we'll talk about the death of your
kitten oh did I forget to mention that
he's dead so before getting on the
Blackbird they're approached by a
soldier who's cypher Raige apparently
saved in war I was on the plateau saved
me and for others I just came from
seeing my baby girl's face for the first
time as you see it's bought no emotional
impact whatsoever
soon that won't be necessary range act
in stand me up
um will could you explain why in your
story a man who can still use one leg is
in a wheelchair when clearly he should
just be using crutches you're not okay
okay so while on the ship Jayden watch
through a toothbrush door cuz you know
future as it seems they trapped in ursa
on the ship hey authorized personnel
only Mart we'll go easy on him Sarge
that's the prime commander's son right
there no on that case I better scare the
living shit out of him
maybe it'll give me a promotion Robby's
feeling with the gentleman right now
whether you know it or not the heart's
been fast it's getting a little harder
to breathe your neurobiological system
he's telling it to run but this is just
imagination she sees you kid
but daddy senses a great disturbance in
the doll what's the last known position
of the closest asteroid storm 2,000
kilometers to starboard at +5
declination
I detected graviton vibrations in the
hall how graviton build-up could be a
precursor to mass expansion you know I'm
sure the actors on Star Trek have no
idea what they're saying but at least
they act like they have some idea what
they're saying you sound like a Will
Smith GPS the pull of our own graviton
weight could set the thing off that
strong could be honest in minutes but
son mass expansion
that's just hold course and hope I'm
wrong so just to go over our choices
it's either alter the course lightly or
risk every single person's life on this
ship
well the buttons all the way over there
patrons wanted to a rough line we do
some Hutchison you travel this out of
here where the Anchorage last year it's
closest confirmation signal travelers
now as you can see I've been trained to
emotionally detach myself from any
intent situation just don't ask to leave
the table before finishing dinner I will
deny you so they find the nearest planet
to land on which is of course earth as
the ship is split completely in half and
everything inside is almost totally
destroyed except for our hero who
somehow doesn't have a single solitary
scratch on it
ah let me translate this scene for those
of you who don't speak shallow ah
notice my directing notice my directing
I know there's a character in story
you're supposed to care about but notice
my directing what the hell is that thing
even supposed to do is if like your
child actor so they don't become even
more spoiled future
oh don't worry kid Papa Smith won't
leave anytime soon yeah as he just
happens to be the only other person who
survived this crash what a fuckin
coinkidink confirmed the US is contained
the back of this ship is gone
Rangers cut off Mastodon Triceratops
with both his legs broken he tells his
son that he has to do daddy a solid by
traveling all the way across a shit ton
of what the hell to set off the
emergency beacon every single decision
you make will be life or death
everything on this planet has evolved to
kill humans with all that nasty wildlife
out there he gives his son the best
firearms a futuristic soldier would have
or a double-edged steak knife um well I
can't I hate to keep bringing this up
but can you tell me why a future
obviously filled with these high-tech
laser guns has a kid-friendly version of
a Klingon sword as the only weapon to
fight against giant killer animals yeah
yeah okay take a knee
root yourself in this present moment now
so inspired by his father strong words
nothing can stop this determined
motivated machine of bravery except the
spider what happened I'm fine
oh yeah this is gonna go great but it
doesn't take long for Jaden to find
trouble
my suits turned black I like you but I
think it's something bad
sorry that why I'm so stupid delayed
reaction what I like you but I think
it's something bad
who the fuck cares if you like it kid
buddy Coco Chanel I think that might
actually be the dumbest thing Shyamalan
has ever written
I'm not saying a lot I like you but I
think it's something bad dipshit fashion
is not a priority here does Shyamalan
think that most soldiers bring wardrobe
appeal to their combat scenarios soldier
what is your status
the enemy has a Top Gun and outnumbered
sir what kind of darkness are they
wearing soldier fashionably outdated VP
camp boot sir is there camouflage from
the Ranger Joe catalog or the Rothko
catalog Ranger Joe sir
ah don't they know that Ranger Joe don't
let's see that please tell me your top
combats they're blase fashion sense sir
I got on a black SWAT vest in the black
standard-issue top what about the bottom
soldier I've got a beautiful bohemian
Banana Republic skirt there's wonderful
flower shoes dude let's choose matte
soldiers for doughnuts in fact yes they
do so oh good for a second there I
thought we were gonna be underdressed I
can't but Alicia died back of us
so it turns out the suit he likes senses
danger danger in the form of bloody
baboons do not move
recognize your power this will be your
creation you know will you could give
the epic talk a little break and maybe
speak a bit simple like don't throw
rocks at them don't encourage them to
get reinforcements
don't make noise while swinging your
bullshit stick and don't run away
enticing them to chase you I'm just
saying it might work better if you don't
be trailer ease
he'll rust though despite how clearly
slow he is and that they always just
look a few steps behind him and he does
it just in time - listen - I know you're
excited for this more bland dialogue
I'll go for my Cutlass shoots its pincer
right through my shoulder next thing I
know we're over the cliff falling 30
meters god I am so sick of this
Shyamalan speak the slow talking the
blank stare the fact that nobody ever
uses any goddamn contractions we are all
telling ourselves a story I am dedicated
this will be your creation we were not
alone you do not know cannot leave do
not move he does not need a commanding I
do not misunderstand me why are you
afraid of the ' what did the apostrophe
ever do to you did the apostrophe kill
your family did the apostrophe have you
cosign on a loan that you knew you
couldn't pay back tell Michel Milan to
tell me so I can finally start fucking
understand the stupid dumbass shit that
you put in your boobies got it so
parable cadet you will get through this
movie I'm trying Will Smith but you just
chose the dumbest as directed are you
cool for this project god help me get
through this
it's alright cadet I know the stories a
young adult book for five-year-olds
I know it's directed by the most
egocentric fafsas Brett Ratner but you
will get through this movie but it's so
hard well Smith you just made it so
stupid
all right take a knee Wow
you can run you live at least for a
while
and dying on your bed many years later
but would you be willing to trade all
the days from this day to that for one
chance just one chance to come back here
and tell your enemies that they may take
our life
that's right heart what bravery you're
blowing brain heart
the night is dark is just before the
dark night do or do not at star wars do
unto others the Bible do wah Diddy
that's gibberish 2+2 that's basic math
you have nothing original to offer do
you you are every wise tough mentor that
has ever existed in anything ever aren't
you how about this one two eggs a cup of
sugar 1/2 a cup of butter that's a
recipe for Cajun yeah I got nothing
leave the story to the storytellers wait
I have two other kids to promote
nepotism right
you
so Jada makes his way to a cliff which
he thinks he can manage through but
cypher Raige okay I'm just gonna have a
puppet me say it because it's the only
way to fully embrace the ridiculousness
of it but cypher Raige thinks it's too
dangerous for him to jump abort mission
return to the ship
no bad that was that
no bad what the Christopher Walken go
through puberty backwards no fat no duh
you wouldn't give any other Ranger that
order
you are not a ranger you're wrong I'm
not a coward you're the coward
I'm not gonna I'm not a count you hear
that audience I don't even at all to get
me through a movie unless it's Jackie
Chan Keanu Reeves on my own frigging dad
twice he jumps off gliding through the
air until a giant eagle picks him up and
feeds into her young who apparently
doesn't believe in cutting up her food
but because pacing is an urban myth in
this movie a group of mountain lions
immediately attacks after he wakes up no
leave em alone yeah come on they were
trying to eat me
even though he tried to save them the
Lions killed all the baby chicks which
means dinner for what I guess or she
just lets him go hmm what was their line
from earlier again everything on this
planet has evolved to kill humans unless
it's kind of ethically taboo I mean come
on
these animals have appearances to keep
up screw years of survival instinct and
primal hunger if work out around that
this eagle killed a food source that
unsuccessfully saved her kids well she
just kept turning looks at her book club
jadynn puts a raft together after losing
communication with his father and starts
dreaming about his sister whose death he
felt like he caused years ago when he
was auditioning for the role of Annie I
was just supposed to come out that day
no you weren't but you did the right
thing
why couldn't you ghost
you are aware you're asking that
question to a goat right now you gotta
get up I memorized some of Moby Dick
guitar get up all that most mountains in
torment ha wait Guster's of the Lisa
she's a doofus like the Batman villain
that helps you as soon as he wakes up he
finds that his warm summer within
seconds is transformed into a deadly
winter please in Chicago we call that
Thursday he seems done for until
something seems to pull him into a warm
spot as the winter melts the next
morning somehow I'm not killing any of
the green plant life can I get a is what
I thought he takes a gander at who came
to his rescue
oh I guess the Eagle cared so much about
being morally cleansed that she gave up
her years of natural evolution that
would adapt to the cold that occurs
every night we appreciate your heroic
totally nonsensical sacrifice he finally
comes across the ship where he discovers
the emergency beacon but even more
important more god damn sharpie things
thank god this ship had no firearms
whatsoever in case they're giant man
killing alien beasts escaped oh look the
giant man killing alien beast escaped
hmm
to make matters worse the beacon doesn't
seem to work unless it's on higher
ground and his father safer ray is
hoping he'll figure that out but seeing
how he can now see him but can't
communicate with him what does he use to
point him in the right direction
take me the commonly known psychic
connection between father and son the
peak it was father beacon
from the peak of that mountain
[Music]
okay I guess you could claim this is all
coincidence that his son just happened
to take a knee when his father said it
just happened to notice the mountain
when his father said as well but come on
we all know they're pushing some sort of
bond that's connecting them across hills
and valleys to keep helping him on his
quest Honda just put little wings on the
faster than have him go so he climbs the
giant volcano to get a better signal but
is attacked by the Versa who seems to
just be a more cartoony version of the
bug from men in black jana makes it to
the top of the mountain but the earths
catches up and fuss Jayden finally gives
in to whatever e Shyamalan actor
eventually has to give into surrendering
all emotion
I have been Shama lized I show emotion
to none but more importantly cannot for
what anybody thinks about my work
that is the Shyamalan way
Will Smith does his interpretation of
the audience's entrance
boy
[Music]
so the beacon is sent an emergency team
is sent the movie takes a minute to
buffer and his father turns out okay
[Music]
stab me up
general SS Stan me oh oh look it's just
like that earlier seeing with that guy
who we now clearly realized was only in
the movie to give us the scene like that
earlier scene with that guy
well isn't that so cleverly woven in
[Music]
yeah I want to work with mom well I do
all my kids who film something with me
say that
and that was after birth better known as
shovel on bomb number five
okay the credit that it's not as bad as
some of his other films I mean at heart
it could actually be an entertaining kid
story and I think Jaden Smith could pull
off a good performance if he had a
better script he certainly done it in
the past but this is certainly not the
performance and this is certainly not
the script it reduces one of the coolest
actors ever to a lifeless onion ring it
looks and sounds like every sci-fi film
you've seen in the past 20 years and
just like most Shyamalan films the
pacing acting and writing are all
pretentious nonsensical and dull as shit
it makes no sense it's not interesting
and have the ideas in it are just
friggin insane especially that scene
with the father-son bond I mean how did
that add up at all
go go to the Internet and tell all your
fans that the movie was great Danna Will
Smith we're not even fathering sons we
even buy your movies logic how does this
make any sense the magic of my trash
Anolon twists for you see I am your
father
no you're not brother nope sister you
know puppy not a person french vanilla
now you're just naming coffee creamers
hi I'm really
Shyamalan damnit am I really so
predictable how you even here I kill you
to time I'm Shyamalan nothing with my
name on it makes any sense if you want
continuity go watch it link our video oh
ha ha ha ha why does everybody keep on
hiring me all of my work is she
[Music]
you
no bad